the eclipse that occurs on July 11th is
a total solar eclipse and it takes place
in the South Pacific the path of the
moon shadow starts about a thousand
miles north of New Zealand sweeps across
the Pacific Ocean and it ends at sunset
in Tierra del Fuego in Chile and
Argentina totality will last up to about
5 minutes and 20 seconds if you're at
the right spot one of the most unique
things about this particular Eclipse is
that it crosses a very interesting
archaeological site Easter Island and on
Easter Island they're at these great
statues that were erected a thousand
1500 years ago a lot of mystery about
these statues but in any case this is
the first total eclipse that's hit the
island in about 1400 years so during a
total solar eclipse the moon comes
between the Sun and the earth and it
casts a shadow on the earth and for
those people that happen to be in that
that small area where the shadow is
they're going to experience what we call
a total solar eclipse and basically the
moon exactly blocks out the solar disk
which is a good thing for those of us
that study the outer atmosphere because
in blocking out the very very bright
solar disk we are then able to view the
outer atmosphere called the corona which
is much less bright it's about a million
times less bright than the disk so the
the solar eclipse provides a rare
opportunity to view the outer atmosphere
and the moon just happens to be at the
exact perfect distance away from the
earth that it completely blocks out just
the disk of the Sun
you